[Applaudissements]
alors marc série ma vie j'ai combattu
cette justice a alors en fait j'ai un
huissier c'est pas la peine de venir
mais merci quand même quand vous appelez
gianni ça va bien tout va très bien
gianni merci le passé des vedettes
russes et de justice est ce que vous
voulez toucher mon front pour voir qu'il
n'ya pas de colle allez-y tout c'est
vrai dans non je n'ai rien n'a pas rien
la peau grâce à les y toucher les
gobelets toucher les gobelets alors je
vais je vais mettre ici 6 il faut
toucher ce que je vais décoller comme ça
allez juste à ma mère s'est réalisé son
truc mais regardez ce que j'arrive à
faire vous allez essayer chez vous
également et ce sera dans le livre des
records puisque personne n'a jamais
laissé nous vous jure que c'est vrai
réalisée sans trucage ceci sans intérêt
non plus alors
et ces essais légiste autour de la table
de vous coller ce gobelet sur le front
allez-y jean luc lemoine
j'en ai toujours rêvé d'aller sillonner
les allées très vite
merci gérard louvin front enora et nora
les i c'est impossible et nohra le
croyais à cette arme c'est impossible
eh bien je vais vous montrer ce soir
tout c'est possible le fakir en mousse
chez moi je subis changement et même
boucher vous de ne pas faire de bruit
j'ai besoin de toute la concentration
c'est dangereux pardon
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant essayer avec deux
côtés non il faut battre un record du
monde on le ferait avec des missions ouf
ça c'est que ça n'a jamais été fait à la
télévision ou quoi que ce soit fatigue
diaries et serre les mains et copains
pas trop de risques sur les allées
[Applaudissements]
licorne c'est la double du corps vers la
triple moi je tombe
c'est super c'est génial c'est hambourg
un petit peu trop tôt ses parents
ouah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est chez vous la dame qui est avec
nous a donc mais m cayla dans les
flammes mais rien fait partie du bureau
et à leurs cadets